قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان الحرب في المنطقه سوف تتسع ما
لم يتم وقف جرائم القوات الاسرائيليه في
قطاع غزه واضاف كنعاني ان الاحداث التي
يشهدها البحر الاحمر ناجمه عن الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه والدعم الامريكي وفق
تعبيره في حال لم يتم ايقاف جرائم الكيان
الصهيوني ضد الشعب الفلسطيني في غزه فسوف
يتسع نطاق الحرب نشهد اتساع رقعه الحرب
نتيجه عدم اكتراث الولايات المتحده
بالتحذيرات من ذلك ان توقف جرائم الحرب
الصهيونيه والحد من اتساع رقعه الحرب
يتطلب اجراءات مؤثره لا نشهدها من واشنطن
وحلفائها الغربيين هناك تناقض بين الاقوال
والافعال الامريكيه اذاء الحرب في غزه
احداث البحر الاحمر ناجمه عن الحرب
الصهيونيه والدعم
الامريكي